[Music]
the Supreme Court ruling was a
tremendous victory for akka we have to
be tough and we have to be safe and we
have to be secure this is a moral moment
for our nation for a president who
openly wants to put a religious test on
citizenship this is not a religious band
and you're picking out countries with
higher threat levels with a poor vetting
process so it makes sense and I think
this really nice is safer well today the
Supreme Court handing President Trump
and his administration a big win
upholding travel ban 3.0 5-4 decision
the majority you see the justices voting
in the majority there and the dissenting
the opinion on the majority saying quote
prod the proclamation is squarely within
the scope of presidential authority
under federal law and need neither
dissent even attempts and a serious
argument to the contrary the dissent
written by justice Sotomayor says quote
this repackaging does little to cleanse
presidential proclamation number 96 for
five of the appearance of discrimination
that the president's words have created
based on the evidence in the record a
reasonable observer would conclude that
the proclamation was motivated by
anti-muslim animus with that let's bring
in our panel byron york chief political
correspondent of the Washington Examiner
Molly Hemingway senior editor at the
Federalist and Charles Lane opinion
writer for The Washington Post okay
Byron significant ruling today it was
this was all we were talking about in
the first few months of the Trump
administration and it should have been a
slam dunk for the White House and the
fact that it is not as there was not as
really amazing at John Roberts is
correct it was clearly within the scope
of the president's constitutional powers
and the biggest argument against it was
that even though it was a legitimate
presidential power that this president
Donald Trump had exercised it with
impure motive and you had a situation in
which an executive order
word for word if signed by another
president would have been constitutional
and yet since it was signed by Donald
Trump with his history of anti-muslim
statements it was therefore
unconstitutional it was a that would
have been a crazy legal area
to go into in the court it's a relief
really that the court did not do that
Marlon Chief Justice Roberts
specifically addressed the issue of
whether it was a religious test or not
pointing out that it covered only 8% of
the world's Muslims that it was using a
list that had been developed by a
previous administration the Obama
administration while she's talking there
and that it also included North Korea
and Venezuela so that it was hard to
argue that this was even though this is
what the conversation had been in the
media that this was a Muslim ban and
even Donald Trump referred to it as that
it really is an important decision
dealing with whether the executive has
the authority to make decisions about
national security related to immigration
and it's important also to consider how
the Obama administration fared with the
Supreme Court when it tested executive
authority it repeatedly was turned away
by the courts sometimes by nine nine to
zero decisions so this is something that
I think is the Trump administration can
legitimately be pleased with on the
question of executive authority
interesting reaction from all over
Capitol Hill and elsewhere here's one
commentator on another channel with an
interesting analogy what Osama bin-laden
hope to provoke was a war of
civilization a war between the West and
1 billion Muslims and so what Donald
Trump in this Muslim band signal to the
world is that Muslims are not welcome
here
that this is whether the conservative
justices say that in fact this is about
executive power the president clear
intent was to impose a religious test
and that is as fundamentally unamerican
as anything that he's done over the
course of this presidency what about the
majority opinion that was looking at the
words on the paper there well you know I
would like to just react to that in
tandem with reacting to Byron the Byron
is absolutely right if you just took the
let's say the 3.0 version of this not
the first two which were quite different
the biggest problem was the problem the
president created for himself through
all this extravagant and hostile
rhetoric toward Muslims george w bush of
course who is president
right after 9/11 went out of his way to
signal that the United States did not
have a quarrel with all Muslims just the
Islamist terrorists and so I think that
commentator you just put up there has a
point that the atmospherics around this
we're terrible one of the lessons of
this decision though is not everything
that has terrible atmospherics that's
perhaps even stupid and offensive is
unconstitutional or even in this case
because there was a statutory argument
against it against the statutes either I
don't consider this so much a victory or
even a vindication which is the
president's other word for this I think
what he got from the Supreme Court today
was a rather a grudging almost
acknowledgment that okay you can do this
if you insist there's no there's no
rhetoric in that any of the majority of
concurring opinion saying yeah this was
absolutely necessary etc it was like
well you know we can't stop you we have
no basis to stop you so you can go ahead
but at its heart Mali was an increase in
this 3.0 version of the stipulations to
get in the what these countries were
doing to vet the people who were
actually getting to the US chad was on
the list but then taken off because they
met the stipulations right so it's hard
to argue that it was some arbitrary
lists and in fact I think the first
version of the ban actually would have
held up under the decision-making that
the court had today
another issue where atmospherics was bad
though is that you had a district court
doing an injunction against a national
ruling and this is a trend that we're
seeing a lot particularly during the
Trump administration where district
courts are thwarting national issues and
Clarence Thomas specifically said in his
concurring opinion that this is
something that might have to be taken up
soon to discuss the legality of it the
fact that this was a 5-4 decision is
also significant because it means that
we're getting very narrow decisions
based on you know in on highly political
cases it is a tremendous argument in
favor of those people who did vote for
Donald Trump that they were able to get
a 5-4 decision on this and also the
decision that forbids the state of
California from forcing pro-life groups
to advocate for abortion but the fact
that they're 5-4 decisions means that
we're going to see this court continue
to be a very political issue it shows
also how important being able to have a
nominee that becomes a Supreme Court
justice is in this political world that
we live if Donald Trump ever says
anything bad about Mitch McConnell again
he shouldn't he will I'm sure but but he
shouldn't but look at some of the
precedents that could have happened if
this had gone the other way the the
shackles that have been could have been
put on a future president's ability to
act in national security instances and
also it seemed to want to create some of
the some of the proponents the opponents
of the ban with foreign nationals
physically outside the United States
seem to create some sort of
constitutional right of entry into the
United States and that would have been a
terrible precedent our late friend
Charles Krauthammer weighed in on this
last year
I'm not against tightening the vetting
we should but I think what we're saying
is the kind of kabuki that we do as a
way to make ourselves think that we are
safer from terrorism there are a lot of
sources of terrorism the whole list
probably at the at the bottom is the
idea of infiltration from these states
these are seven states in 15 years since
9/11 there hasn't been a single murder
of an American by a national of these
two countries Chuck well that's another
good point is that quite a few of the
recent lone wolf attacks have taken
place by people who are either born in
the United States or who were here on
green cards and the relationship between
terrorism these particular countries
though not completely disjointed is a
little tenuous it's just that I think
what the court was wrestling with
particularly justices Robert Chief
Justice Roberts and Justice Kennedy do
we take this power away from all future
presidents because we're so uncertain
about the trustworthiness of the current
one
and I think they felt we're gonna have
to swallow this exercise of the power in
the case of a very very inflammatory
president because it could be used
legitimately when the presidency is
occupied by a different person later on
let's look at the circuit courts that
were willing to do that not just the
Ninth Circuit the Fourth Circuit all the
judges short of the Supreme Court big
majorities were willing to do that with
the president and some of them will be
changed because as the judges get
through the process up on Capitol Hill
including Ninth Circuit